when the largest plane on the planet
comes to town it tends to attract
attention
that's why 20,000 people turned out to
see the Antonov an-225 landing in Perth
Australia
earlier this week also known as the
Maria the truly jumbo jet is 275 feet
long and 288 feet wide it stacks up
superlatives it's the longest bodied
longest winged and heaviest plane of the
sky thanks to six engines and heavy
landing gear with 32 wheels the 600 ton
aircraft can carry 250 tons of cargo
loaded through its nose the Soviet Union
designed the plane to carry its space
shuttle on its back NASA used modified
747 jumbo jets for the same purpose but
the an-225 is the only one of its kind
because the Soviet Union collapsed
before it got around to building anymore
so an-225 flights are pretty rare these
days the plane sometimes used to carry
supplies to areas hit by natural
disasters it was in Perth to drop off a
117 tonne mining generator the size of a
bedroom so you see why it attracts
crowds wherever it goes it's an
engineering marvel and frankly if you
don't see it with your own eyes it's
hard to believe it can fly